بدات الاحداث عندما كسر اطلاق نار هدوء
الدائره العاشره في العاصمه باريس قبيل
وقت الظهيره وهي منطقه حيويه تجاريه
يقصدها بكثافه افراد الجاريه الكرديه في
فرنسا
المنفذ كما كشفت التحقيقات الاوليه فرنسي
في التاسعه والستون من العمر اطلق النار
داخل مركز ثقافي كردي وصالون لتصفيف الشعر
قتل ثلاثه اشخاص واصيب اخرون نقلوا لتلقي
العلاج الجاني وفق السلطات الفرنسيه ذو
سوابق في معادات المهاجرين فقد قالت
المدعيه العامه انه متهم بطعن شخصين على
الاقل بسكين في مخيم للمهاجرين في هجوم
وقع في شهر ديسمبر من السنه الماضيه
على عجل على وزير الداخليه جيراننا الى
باريس للوقوف على حيثيه الواقعه قادما من
شمال البلاد حيث كان في زياره عمل
الذي اراد قتلها هؤلاء الاشخاص الثلاثه قد
فعل ذلك تحديدا لانهم من الاكراد ومن
الواضح انه اراد مهاجمه الاجانب يجب ان
نعرف من التحقيق القضائي الذي راسه المدعي
العام هل يتعلق الامر بالاكراد بشكل خاص
لكن في الوقت الحالي لا يوجد عنصر يسمح
لنا بتاكيد ذلك
لكنه وجود وزير الداخليه في موقع الهجوم
لم يمر بسلام فقد تجمعت حشود من الجاليه
الكرديه حول طوق الامني الذي يحيط بالوزير
ما هي الا لحظات حتى اصطدم المحتجون
الاكراد بقوات الشرطه التي استخدمت الغاز
المسيله للدموع لتفريقهم بينما القى
المتظاهرون مقذوفات على رجال الشرطه
واحرقوا صناديق القمامه
[تصفيق]
تطور المشهد طوال الساعه اللاحقه حتى حل
الظلام وعلى وقع الصدمه قال افرد من
الجاليه الكرديه في باريس لوسائل الاعلام
ان الشرطه تحذرته مؤخرا من تهديدات لاهداف
كرديه وطالبوا بتحقيق العداله وانصافهم
جاءت حادثه الجمعه لتلقي مزيدا من الاضواء
على مشاعر الكراهيه المهاجرين في فرنسا
وهي التي كانت وقودا لحملات انتخابات
للمنتمين لاحزاب اقصى اليمن